In real life, fast memories are managed
automatically in hardware or
by the operating system.
Caches are one example.
Now, these automatically managed
fast memories are great.
You can go about your merry way,
writing code and
algorithms that are oblivious to
what's happening under the hood.
The only problem is that, when you
do that, performance can suffer.
Think of the resource
oblivious binary search
compared to a resource
aware bee tree search.
But bee trees have a problem too.
You need to tune that bee perameter
in a machine specific way,
which effects portability.
So, this leads us to a really
interesting question.
Is there a different algorithm or
data structure that would be efficient,
no matter what the memory hierarchy
looks like or how it's managed?
In 1999, Matteo Frigo,
Charles Leiserson, and
a bunch of other MIT yahoos,
discovered a way to be cache oblivious,
at least for basic problems like
matrix multiply and sorting.
And that friends, is the topic of this
lesson, cache oblivious algorithms.